all right let's get into this story
ladies and gentlemen from timcast.com
breaking Twitter has interfered in
elections Elon Musk confirms Twitter 2.0
will be far more effective transparent
and even-handed new Twitter owner Elon
Musk confirmed the Tweet response the
outlet has interfered in elections now
let's slow down there a minute just a
moment ago in the intro to the show we
said is this Hunter Biden laptop stuff
because we know that happened and we all
think that was election interference but
Elon Musk may be talking about something
deeper and I think that's probably true
even if it is just Hunter Biden laptop
you know a scuttlebutt I think when you
have the CEO the owner of Twitter coming
out saying this is how we interpret what
was done here with the with the app not
he Now controls that still says
something in and of itself but just a
moment ago Alx you are mentioning that
uh you think this is something more yeah
I think this is mentioning back to when
he uh teased the release of the Twitter
files and yes a lot of people did think
that was is referencing the hunter Biden
laptop but I'm hearing from behind the
scenes so I I have here from Ali
Alexander says that internally it's been
described of years of confessions within
the company's slack Channel and
employees are knowingly subverting the
rules in terms of service and that the
sheer volume hasn't completely been
compiled yet so that's he like initially
wanted to release this all like when he
found it out Elon yes
um but like so let's yeah sorry let's
slow down um you're saying behind the
scenes there's confessions people who
work at Twitter admitting to
intentionally interfering yes and I
think so my theory would be for
suspending accounts you'd probably have
to give a justification for it so I'm
not sure if they attach the slack chats
to you say like their panel on there
but I would say that they would be a
giving a reason or B they just never
thought this would happen they never
thought that the company would be taken
over so they viewed that as a safe space
for them to have these conversations
what's uh what's uh Ali Alexander's
connection to what's going on Twitter
um he just has a bunch of tech
connections similar to mine as well I've
conversed with people that are close to
Elon as well
um and we've been in kind of the same
circles that that way level of
confidence on this information being
correct pretty high pretty high you
think 99 i i as As a matter of opinion
based on what I know about Twitter and
what we've seen over the past few years
I'd believe it outright but we'll see
I'd love to see the documents come out I
think we're gonna find out why I think
it was what was it vinjaya that was
crying
yeah I think I think I think we're going
to find out why uh they were crying in
just a little bit because we have to
understand this interference didn't just
happen in 2020 this has been going on
for a very long time in 2008 right
before the midterm elections a lot of
people got their accounts taken down
like Laura Loomer so we know that
foreign governments also spied on
people's private DMS we also know that a
lot of private information was hacked so
this is what's public now what's
happening behind the scenes what else
are they doing how else are they
finagling the algorithm what else are
they doing when it comes to bots when it
comes to manipulating people's opinions
when it comes to people going to the
voting box man I think we're going to
find out a lot of crazy stuff very soon
yeah I spent about five years moderating
as an administrator at mines and
basically with this kind of power and
control and unless you've done this job
you don't really I doubt you would
understand the level of power you have
is just a cheap employee you can push a
button and turn someone's account off
and they have no recourse and you know
that and and you can do if you your
emotions are telling you maybe that
violates the rules in this way maybe you
can turn it off and then or you can
upscale it to your supervisor and if
they agree with you you can turn it off
or limit the ideas and see which ideas
and promote certain ideas and demote and
there's no recourse you'd never get
punished for it it's the most empowering
like intoxicatingly powerful I don't
think humans should have that level of
authority at this stage I think we need
like a crowd sourced you know Judiciary
System in social media yeah because that
power is absolute when you can control
what people think what what goes into
people's minds that is god-like power
and authority that obviously people are
going to be abusing for their own
personal benefit because how can you not
when you have so many things at stake
here and when you have free speech
standing in the way destroying so many
powerful PR uh campaigns that they've
been trying to sell the American public
on and the public of the world
so it's going to be interesting I mean
that I I think I I think there's going
to be some significant changes because
of this and I think it's going to shock
a lot of people personally what about
you guys uh uh there's definitely going
to be changes
um it was it was so hard to be an
administrator uh for social network
because you're constantly fighting with
your own morals and trying to do what
the terms say
uh that's it's just I that's maybe
that's not an answer to your question of
what's going to happen next I think
what's going to happen next is he's
going to expose everything the
government's going to freak out they're
going to try and shut down Twitter
Twitter's going to turn into an
algorithm instead of a social like
instead of a website if they're going to
decentralize it'll become something that
plugs into other websites to facilitate
inner communication
I don't know like when has something
like this happened before where it's a
it's a billionaire taking over a company
in this way and then and threatening to
expose stuff like this so I think what
he's doing is smart though because if
you notice in the past two weeks all of
these things so he reinstates Donald
Trump he says he wants to give Mass
Embassy and like to all of these
accounts and then also he's saying he's
going to release the hunter button files
and in the same week he's picking a
fight with Apple
two days later he's meeting with with
the head of Apple you know and they're
like oh well they have they had no plans
to do that so that's him just shrunk
like showing his strong arm basically
saying don't mess with me because like I
number one all of this is coming out and
number two like it's gonna look really
bad if you pull us off the App Store
like do you know how bad that would look
if Twitter got pulled off the app store
Apple stock would would drop yeah I
don't know about you know double dish or
anything like that but they get hurt by
it I know especially and then Elon would
make his new phone which would challenge
Apple directly and their Monopoly I I
talked about this a couple days ago the
potential for low earth orbit
um satellite Communications the
possibility with Elon with starlink is
that phones may actually be able to send
texts and make calls over starlink not a
lot of data probably probably very
rudimentary but what we're already
seeing with the new iPhone is that it's
got uh two-way satellite tracking of
some sort or SOS I think it has like SOS
or something
so I remember 10 years ago we had I had
a friend who was going to do coverage in
Syria and we bought a two-way satellite
uh texting device it could transmit I
think up to like 120 characters because
the data was so limited and it took a
long time to do and you'd carry it
around and you could send out a use the
app to send out a very simple message
and you could use it to text to tweet so
it was like wow now the iPhone the new
one comes with this like internally
imagine what would happen
if you've got Elon Musk rolling out a
new phone that has rudimentary
Communications texting now why would he
want Twitter well with us with limited
data transference you'd still be able to
tweet you'd be able to communicate
globally over low earth orbit satellite
with just the phone because you can
transmit a few a few a few characters
that makes me feel like maybe it may be
an X phone or something isn't the
working but think about what happens
then there was this great thread that
this dude put up on Twitter where he
said how do you think the intelligence
agencies react to severing everyone from
their grid they've got they've got
um big facilities that wiretap the the
internet cables that go through the
undersea cables Elon puts them all on
his satellite Network and now they've
got to come to him and he controls the
single access point to spying well
that's dangerous we shouldn't have it no
individual should control the action
sure it's a communication yeah but they
but the intelligence agencies do every
undersea cable you think they're not
tapping that data I think they are they
absolutely are or they're trying to and
maybe maybe we're all sitting here like
oh Elon so great we're showing free
speech and what he's really doing is
making an excuse to centralize
Communications so that's a single point
for everyone in the world to have all
their data collected and tracked he's
also said that he wants to revolutionize
the DM feature to make it more like
signal so it seems like he's already
trying to replace text messaging there
and then he also says that he wants to
make Twitter into the X app or the
everything app basically
um similar to what they have in China
with WeChat like everything that they
have in there in their life is
centralized in that one app we almost
we'd considered streaming on Twitter I
think it's a day of the tech technology
right now to handle it yeah they've had
it for for a while so like if we were to
get pulled down on this on this network
YouTube that we would it's like striking
up like Twitter is now the HBO of
Television currently it's really weird
so like they had Periscope but then they
kind of kicked that same same they did
with Vine but they kept the like
infrastructure I guess so you can go
live on it but it's the features are
very limited on it it's just a tweet
with the live video you can't really do
much with it but then they they released
that uh thing today where they said that
they're going to have capabilities of
like two hour uploads or something like
as a hard upload 40 gigabytes 40
gigabytes yeah two hours that's massive
two hours that's right only only for
Twitter blue subscribers though smart oh
that's smart yep wow not first but not
for everyone you know so my question is
I tweeted you know my pitch is on audio
video tab rev share and premium
subscriber content uh abilities which
which already exists with the super
follow or the content drivers so am I
going to spend eight bucks a month to
get access to this to upload my videos
that Elon then has to pay me for because
that seems a little redundant you know
uh it's it's an interesting model and
mines has that too you sign up for mines
Pro and then once you do you're able to
move your mind's tokens off chain onto
your wallet so you can actually if you
want to make money off mines you got to
pay to be able to make money off mines
and that helps the program are you
saying uh you need Twitter blue to
upload and create two hour videos or to
watch or both
um to upload I think so okay but anyone
can watch yeah I'm pretty sure yeah that
would make sense well I'm open to trying
new networks you know we don't have to
sit on one network forever no it's going
to be crazy yeah I I I think people uh
Luke you brought this up he wants to
make it like uh WeChat yeah yeah I mean
we were talking about this for uh a very
long time because he made similar
announcements and speeches saying
everyone depends on almost every aspect
of their life in China based on this one
particular app that they have to go
through for everything their their jobs
their applications their resumes their
food orders their their entertainment
all of that is controlled in one app
that the Chinese government is watching
and controlling and of course dictating
what people can and cannot say so that's
a bad thing right well it's it's
centralized
and think about that if this really does
go in the direction of an X phone and
then we're all getting these phones like
wow they use starlink so I can call and
text and use Twitter and you know can't
watch movies or anything
then that is a singular Network taking
all data if we get to that point where
we're no longer using undersea cables
there's there's definitely benefits to
it but then
they're going to spy on everyone
everywhere so thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time